so you have worked with Marvel before of
course on what if and Miss Marvel two
questions about that what is something
about the composing process that has
stayed consistent from Project to
project to project but then I want to
know a unique challenge that was
specific to the Marvels great question
um the thing that stays consistent in
any film project but particularly the
MCU is you have to write an iconic theme
you've got to have two to four bars of
Music something that is instantly
recognizable instantly singable so that
is consistent across projects you've got
to write that theme people have got to
love it and it's got to be able to be
Associated it's it's a signature for
each project for this one for the
Marvels I think figuring out what space
Sounds like was the big the big the big
one um there's actually no sound in
space sound IS F felt in space and not
heard so how do you do that I mean there
are a lot of ways which I can get into
if you're interested I am because I
think I know one of those ways and I
read a lot about uh the drumming in the
movie which which makes all the sense in
the world to me and I'm very excited to
hear in context of the full future well
I'll tell you about it it a lot of um a
lot of the sounds of space were created
in conjunction with this incredible
percussionist Evelyn Glenny here's the
thing about Evelyn she's profoundly deaf
so she when she plays she actually
doesn't wear shoes she feels the sound
through her body which is exactly how
you feel in space it's so crazy so we
started creating sounds together that
were not like anything that you have
ever heard before and because of the way
that she listens and it's a very
physical thing for her I think that that
that permeates every aspect of the Sonic
life of this project so that was one way
the other way which is like way sillier
is we went to um a prop House in Burbank
and we rented space junk like literally
stuff that fell out of the sky what is
the most random piece of space junk you
found and maybe did it also make into
the sound of the movie yeah it did um I
think these titanium discs that which
are really weird because they're super
light like they look like they'd be
heavy but they're really light and you
can bow them and it's this incredible
sound it's like nothing you've ever
heard oh you didn't just use it as
inspiration you actually used these pie
basically I went there and we we figured
out how you could make sounds out of
them and then anything that you could
like we went there with like a bow and
various beers and stuff like that and
anything that you can make a sound out
of we rented and then and then used in
the film just emphasizes that music can
come come from literally anywhere I love
it absolutely listen we could go around
this room and make a score for film with
just what's hanging these lights your
shoes you know I don't know what else is
hanging out here I but we could make we
could play anything in here and make a
cool score the next time I cross path
with you at a junket we're not talking
about the movie we are making a junket
score we can do it I love let go let's
go so I want to go back to the idea of
themes because I had read that you went
back and you listened to some very
iconic Marvel themes and it was making
me curious which one of the bunch did
you find most influential when you
started to tackle the themes in the
Marvels I think the Avengers maybe
because this is an Avengers style film
so I think the energy and also this idea
of creating something new for you know
for a team rather than kind of focusing
on individual characters I think that
was something that influenced me a lot
and I I think that's a part of it I
think the energy of that is it you know
plays a role in this and and I think
think Alan Sylvester is really good at
getting a motor going so I think a
musical motor and so I think that that
had an influence on me but I also go to
a lot of like weird musical sources like
I mean this is this is going to sound
completely crazy but there's this moment
in the beginning of an opera by this
English composer Benjamin Brittain that
are these like strings kind of sliding
around and that had a huge influence on
me and the theme opens that way oh I
love it I want to jump to crafting a
theme for a villain what pointers tips
or tricks would you give to another
composer looking to craft a theme for a
villain that doesn't just say like this
is a bad guy but rather reflects the
fact that that character has nuance and
isn't just villain and nothing more well
I think that that you I mean you
captured exactly the point is with a
hero and with a villain you want to have
something that can cover an emotional
range right because not every not every
villain is totally bad and not every
hero is totally good that doesn't make
for an interesting movie and it
certainly doesn't make for an
interesting score so I think going for
something unusual for the villain was
important um I think going for something
that I think I the instrumentation that
I chose was quite unusual um and I think
having something that kind of
slithered was really important for this
particular person I like a lot of the
score that I was able to uh check out
that's the track that I've been relising
to the most since I received it I love
it it's pretty groovy do uh the flurin
have a theme and if not what specific
sounds were you using most for them I am
going to leave that to the audience to
find out when you see it mostly because
there'll be some wonderful surprises
there okay I like really big moments I
will take that I I want all the big
moments for the you love it you will
love it you will laugh out loud this
question the answer might just be no but
I was reading the uh credits for the
film and I noticed that some of John
opman scores from the X-Men movies were
credited is that something you got to
work with and if so how did you go about
incorporating them in your own original
score I think we'll leave that to to to
big surprises too okay go Thursday night
and you can find out all the answers to
these questions again another excellent
tease I'll end with a fun question just
given what the Marvels go through in
this movie I am curious if you had the
opportunity to swap places with two
other artists in this industry to walk
in their shoes experience their
day-to-day what two artists would you
choose and
why God what a great question there's a
question I've never been asked my job is
done step
Spielberg I think maybe to
really feel that kind
of like directoral finesse I think is
something that's
that he that he has that's amazing and
another person
um God I don't know I I think how about
Dorothy arner and you're gonna ask me
who is Dorothy arner yes I am Dorothy
arner was the first woman to be admitted
to the DGA she was a director in the
Golden Age of Hollywood and she directed
tons of movies and how she got away with
what she got away with I would love to
jump into her body and figure that out
excellent choices right there thank you
so much for your time today
congratulations on this and American
fiction thank you very much I appr be
hearing your name a whole lot in the
coming months well listen thanks for
being so well prepared you had great
questions